amnesty or no amnesty that is the
question whether tis nobler in the minds
of voters to suffer the slings and
arrows of outrageous headlines or to
take arms against a CNN of troubles and
by Amnesty and them amnesty amnesty
amnesty perchance more dreamers ah
there's the rub for in that lawless
pandering more dreamers may come when we
have shuffled off this constitutional
order that must give us pause to Daka
illegal aliens so-called dreamers
according to Democrats have been
arrested in separate incidents for human
trafficking in my own sunny state of
California one arrest occurred last
Wednesday when Torrey Pines Beach
resident called the cops for suspected
trafficking borders agents found the
driver 20 year-old dreamer as well as
two Mexican nationals when he was
smuggling them in his car another 22
year old illegal alien also a dreamer by
Democrat lights was arrested in Campo
California also for charges related to
human trafficking California dreamin
means you won't be safe as long as
you're in LA all of this comes as
Democrats in Congress desperately try to
ram through a bill to legalize on the
low end 800,000 illegal aliens brought
to the US as children but for more
likely upwards of 3.6 million illegal
aliens we will analyze Democrat dreams
of amnesty and electoral dominance
point-by-point live i'll i then philip
webmin ariel davidson and amber Athey
joined the panel of deplorable z-- to
discuss the state of the union
throughout history the six democrats
state of the union rebuttals this year
six probably more by the time i finish
this show and democrats sacramental view
of late term abortion i'm michael noland
this is the michael knowles show
[Music]
so much to get to today the trouble with
you Familia allottee catches up with
them and then you get the Chico Marx
line who you gonna believe me or your
own eyes your own Lionel eyes Democrats
have labeled a massive group of illegal
aliens dreamers and they're only
referring to illegal aliens brought to
the United States when they were minors
no fault of their own they say their
parents fault these are the people
unconstitutionally protected by Barack
Obama's daca program the trouble with
daca is that it only protects a certain
group of illegal aliens brought to the
US as minors it only protects those who
were born after June 15 1981 have lived
in the u.s. continuously since June 15
2007 and registered for the program
between June 2012 and September 2017
trouble is that covers nowhere near all
of the illegal aliens brought to the US
as children Steny Hoyer Democrats House
Minority Whip even admitted as much when
he pointed out that the euphemism
dreamer and the technical term daca
recipient are not a distinction without
a difference there's there is a
difference between those two things
Democrats want to pretend there aren't
two weeks ago USA Today gave the fuller
story the real number of illegal aliens
brought over as children is around 3.6
million four and a half times as many as
Democrats admit in all of their
legislative maneuvering that is an
estimated third of all illegal aliens in
the US and that doesn't count the
millions of immediate family members who
are already citizens that's a convenient
omission
since amnesty for the dreamers would be
a dream come true for Democrats
according to Pew Research Hispanics are
five times as likely to identify with
the Democrat Party is with the GOP even
among registered voters the trend holds
there are well over four times as many
Hispanic voters registered with the
Democrats as with Republicans even for
Hispanics who don't identify with either
party
they are two and a quarter times more
likely to lean toward Democrats
native-born Hispanics are four point
four times as likely to identify with
Democrats foreign-born Hispanics are
five point six times as likely to
identify with Democrats and that
includes Cubans who are Republicans my
favorite group of immigrants the Cubans
because they bring good cigars and
culture and vote for
look ins that even includes them in that
number Ronald Reagan used to say that
Hispanics are Republicans they just
don't know it yet that's because they
work hard and go to church two traits
that are Anathem to Democrats he he may
have been right
Hispanics born in the u.s. are slightly
less likely to identify with Democrats
as those who were born outside the US
but the data show it's still going to
take a long time for Hispanic voters to
realize that they're Republicans and if
we're going to give amnesty to three
point six million new likely Democrat
voters there may not be a Republican
Party around by the time they do realize
it there are some interesting data among
how party affiliation changes over time
so foreign-born Hispanics who've been
here less than 10 years are just under
three times as likely to identify
Democrat probably because they got here
during Barack Obama's terrible
administration and they realized this
party has nothing to offer to the
country other than division and envy
that number though jumps way up to eight
point seven five times as many Hispanics
who lived in the US for 10 to 14 years
identifying as Democrat eight point
seven five times as likely that number
holds around eight point two times as
many Hispanics who've lived here 15 to
19 years identifying as Democrat then it
drops back down a little bit to a still
terrifying five point four times as many
Hispanics who have lived in the US for
20 years or more identifying as
Democrats as those who identify as
Republicans well over five times as many
identifying as Democrats any way you
slice it
amnesty means electoral death for
Republicans Democrats even admit as much
that's why they want it so bad earlier
this month a memo leaked from the Center
for American Progress Action Fund
explaining that amnesty for illegal
aliens constitutes quote a critical
component of the Democratic Party's
future electoral success that memo was
co-authored by former Hillary Clinton
communications director Jennifer
Palmieri
and it was sent around to allies calling
on Democrats to quote refused to offer
any votes for Republican spending bills
that do not offer a fix for dreamers and
instead appropriate funds to deport them
Barack Obama's former domestic policy
director Cecilia muñoz insists quote the
right policies to be
as generous as possible we know the
success of Daka it's good for the
country and this has overwhelming
support from around the country from
people on both sides of the aisle there
is no reason to limit who is eligible
typically for an Obama policy adviser
absolutely nothing she said is true
according to a late 2017 poll by morning
consult and political Politico Politico
it's a fake news organization and I just
pronounced their name wrong so that's
fake news of fake news
but according to morning consult in
Politico Politico leans left by the way
but even according to them just 29% of
Americans say giving illegal aliens
brought to the US under the age of 18
giving them amnesty should be a policy
priority just 29% 71% of Americans do
not want amnesty incredibly just 44% of
Democrat voters say amnesty for daca
recipients should be a priority for
Congress to say nothing about the 2.8
million additional illegal aliens who
would receive amnesty through any real
daca deal any real deal is on the table
that means that even the majority of
Democrats oppose amnesty even for the
dreamers and the daca and the people
brought here as children in recent years
the u.s. foreign-born population has
also reached record highs hitting forty
three point two million in 2015 so
anybody who tells you we don't let
immigrants in we're not letting any
immigrants and we have a terrible policy
on immigration that isn't true we're
we're at record highs that number has
steadily climbed since 1965 when famed
drunk driver Ted Kennedy sponsored
legislation replacing the national quota
system with are currently incoherent
immigration regime since that time the
number of immigrants living in the
United States has more than quadrupled
since that kennedy law Ted Kennedy one
of the worst politicians in American
history since his law the number of
immigrants living the US has more than
quadrupled immigrants today account for
thirteen point four percent of the total
u.s. population tripled the immigrant
share of the u.s. population that we had
in 1970 the only time the foreign-born
percentage of the population was this
high was in 1890 after a half-century
period that gave us four and a half
million Irish immigrants including many
wonder
families including my wonderful family
and also the Kennedys lest our
opposition to amnesty be considered
excessively partisan remember that
amnesty is a terrible idea
unconstitutional and humanitarian
grounds as well Barack Obama's executive
amnesty which kicked off this entire
debate about the dreamers is
unconstitutional any way you slice it
it's unconstitutional the President does
not have the authority to subvert
democratically enacted immigration law
he doesn't have the authority to erase
the national borders of the United
States and obviously it goes to that
saying he does not have the right to
illegally fill the country with people
who were exceedingly likely to vote for
his own party now as a matter of federal
spending and taxpayer resources
we're told immigrants are great for the
country they might be great for the
country but on those grounds not so
immigrant led households are far more
likely than native lead households to
receive welfare according to a study by
the Center for Immigration Studies which
advocates lower levels of immigration to
the US the majority of immigrant led
households receive at least one kind of
welfare benefit which could include any
number of them because we have way too
many federal welfare programs but it
could include a Medicaid food stamps
housing assistance school lunches on and
on and on that number drops to just 30%
for households led by native-born
Americans the numbers increase for
houses with children but the comparison
still holds 76 percent of immigrant led
households with children receive welfare
compared with 52 percent of native lead
households with children so you might
say those numbers are far too high all
around of course that's a good argument
for shrinking the government fortunately
the Trump administration is doing just
that but the trend still holds anybody
who tells you otherwise not telling the
truth how about on crime we're told that
illegal aliens don't commit a lot of
crime that those numbers are not true
according to a study from the Crime
Prevention Research Center by John our
lot just in Arizona alone illegal aliens
are 142 percent more likely to be
convicted of a crime than other
Arizonans of course the act of crossing
into a country illegally itself is a
very serious crime that profoundly
disrespects the target country but
than putting that one aside illegal
aliens also tend to commit more serious
crimes here they serve ten point five
percent longer sentences they're more
likely to be classified as dangerous
they are 45% more likely to be gang
members than US citizens even adjusting
for the fact that young people commit
crime at higher rates because that's
what we're told we're told well most
these people are young young people
commit crime at higher rates that's how
you explain those statistics but even
controlling for that a young illegal
aliens commit crime at twice the rate of
young US citizens lot also notes that
these numbers likely underestimate the
share of crime committed by illegal
aliens the federal government
notoriously is a very opaque on
releasing illegal alien crime numbers
but according to the GAO there was a 40
percent and 25 percent increase
respectively in criminal alien
incarcerations in state jails and
prisons between 2003 and 2009 perhaps
the most damning statistic of all
actually comes from the other side it
comes from left-wing outlets fusion and
the Huffington Post
according to a Fusion investigation
eighty percent of women and girls
crossing into the u.s. by way of Mexico
are raped during the journey 80 percent
four out of five women and girls who
cross via Mexico illegally into the US
are raped on their journey that is up
from a previous estimate of 60% given by
Amnesty International
but Democrats don't care about that they
don't care about any of that they care
about one thing and it's winning
elections and their end i rana CLE so
egregiously they demagogue us and they
call people who are conservative bigots
and racists some meanies and whatever
they call us for pointing out what is
clearly in front of our face a Democrat
sent a majority leader Senate Minority
Leader thank goodness
Chuck Schumer typifies Democrats take on
this issue who enter the United States
without our permission are illegal
aliens and illegal aliens should not be
treated the same as people who entered
the US legally president's decision to
end daca was heartless and it was
brainless when we use phrases like
undocumented workers we convey a message
to the American people that their
government is not serious about
combating illegal immigration hundreds
hundreds of thousands of families will
be ripped apart now I know you might
have been confused because you heard
Chuck Schumer the same guy speaking on
both of those times but that was old
Chuck Schumer when it was politically
advantageous to him to pretend that he
didn't want to give amnesty to all of
the illegal aliens and then now he
cannot be honest about his opinion and
say yes we need to give amnesty because
then we'll win all of the elections
quite the turnaround but then the
possibility of finally wiping out the
GOP entirely is a strong incentive to
evolve on the issue country be damned
let's get to our panel to see what they
think about this we have Phillip Wegman
we have Ariel Davidson we have amber
Athey but look I know you want to talk
to all of these people they're going to
give excellent analysis of this issue
but first we can't talk about them
because we need to talk about sleep now
you know I love to sleep I need at least
18 hours a day just to maintain my
beauty rest I had to go the other night
yesterday I was on Fox News at 2:15 in
the morning or something like that
I couldn't get my requisite sleep and I
was I was dead I was destroyed
I couldn't sleep is very important most
people spend a third of their life
sleeping I spend at least two-thirds and
I've moved around a lot of moved from
New York Connecticut California popped
all around the country by buying a
mattress is just awful it is just a
terrible experience I've done it
multiple times helix sleep helix sleep
makes it so much better there were a ton
of online mattress retailers popping up
these days and they all have a
one-size-fits-all solution to a better
sleep now look online is better than
going into those stores if you go into
those stores they you can never compare
prices they always have different names
on they're gonna pounce on you it's
really very hard to tell but for the
online mattresses they just want to sell
you the one product that they make but
one size does not always work as I
frequently point out people usually
spouses have different preferences for
their beds some people you know for
instance I like a firmer mattress and
sweet little ELISA likes a mattress that
I am NOT on so couples have different
decisions helix sleep offers something
that doesn't exist anywhere else a
mattress personalized to your unique
preferences and sleeping style that will
not set you back thousands of dollars so
if you go to helix sleep comms lie
NOLs Kanna wles that's right just like
the last name of JC's wife Knowles take
their simple two to three minutes sleep
quiz they will build you a custom
mattress that will be the best thing
that you have ever slept on I will not
do anything in this world if it takes
more than three minutes I just don't
want to I'm a millennial man I got stuff
to do and I have no attention span go
there that will do it very very quickly
for you four couples they will
personalize each side of the mattress if
men you are like me and you prefer a
firmer mattress and your wife prefers a
mattress that you are not on they they
probably could even figure that out
everyone from GQ to Cosmo to the New
York Times are all talking about helix
once you try it out you will know why
your custom mattress arrives direct to
your door in a week shipping it is
completely free and you can try it for
100 nights risk-free there's no risk at
all no reason not to do it if you don't
love it they will pick it up and refund
you so what should you do you should go
to helix sleep calm slash Knowles KO
wles
right now you will get $50 towards your
custom mattress that is my gift to you
$50 don't say I never did anything for
you helix sleep dot-com slash Knowles KO
wles for $50 off your order
gillich sleep comm slash Knowles okay
let's bring everybody on philip and
amber and arial friends countrymen thank
you for being here
philip the american people are against
amnesty but recent numbers show that
even democrats are now against amnesty
even for illegal aliens brought here
under the age of 18 this was very
shocking for me to read those numbers
why has this shift occurred well i think
that there is a general support for
finding a solution to the dreamer
situation on both the left and the right
side of the aisle since 2000 for crying
out loud Republicans and Democrats have
said that they're gonna do something
about this now President Trump is
actually put forward a deal he's asking
for about 25 billion for border security
five more than what Chuck Schumer
offered immediately before the shutdown
and he's offering amnesty for about 1.8
million dreamers so the question now is
you've got a president who campaigned on
on one single issue which was border
security are Democrats gonna take him up
on this offer because frankly he's
already getting pressure from
you know from his flank from
conservatives on this one so I don't
think Democrats will ever get a better
deal than this it is an incredible deal
and you're right people they always want
a solution we just want to do something
we want to fix it but we also know when
you when you dig down into those numbers
even the majority of Democrats don't so
don't support amnesty as a priority
right so right is is there any it has
there been a shift in public opinion
that doesn't match the shift in the
political negotiations that's going on
well as far as public opinion goes I
mean it's pretty clear that this was the
motivating issue for President Trump on
the campaign trail and you were talking
a second ago about amnesty and how
there's some negative opinions
surrounding that policy I think the
reason why Republicans are willing to
move forward with amnesty for this one
point eight million dreamers is because
they one end to chain migration and also
the Visa Lottery program as a result
they're thinking we can have this
compromise if in the long term we can
stop the flow and so they've they've put
Democrats in a really difficult position
president shrimp has got to deliver that
message tonight if they could end chain
migration and build the wall and
actually limit this even to 1.8 million
it's a it's looking through the future
it's possibly okay there GOP could
possibly weather that storm but if it
gets up to three point six million or
something like in the eighties they
don't actually follow through on border
security could be dicey Ariel is the
solution here just to not give them
amnesty just that we'd not not deport
them not that we have to deport millions
of people but just not give them amnesty
why can't we just do that I think what's
gonna happen is it's gonna continue to
be a political football so if we don't
address it you know at least when we
have a Republican in office which is our
best possible scenario so I look at this
situation sort of you know let's
capitalize on the fact that we have a
Republican in office because I guarantee
if we do have a Democrat in office and
they are the ones to address the creamer
situation it could be entirely different
I think there's also a level of
cognitive dissonance taking place in the
Democratic Party you have to sort of you
know that they called so when when this
doctor deal was offered you know that
there were still cries that this deal
was racist and then you have you know
this is at least Falls a long line of
the Democrats sort of
just pooh-poohing anything that comes
out of anything that comes out of the
GOP brainchild so you know the tax
reform was even though people are
getting thousand dollar bonuses you
still had people on the Left calling it
crumbs
you know the twenty twenty week abortion
ban which a majority of Americans would
have supported you had people on the
Left especially politicians and left
calling it radical so there's definitely
some ways in which when you just asked
Bill earlier about how you know how is
the Overton Window shifted I do think
there's some level of it there's
dissonance between how far left the
progressive element how far left the
progressive element of the Democratic
Party has gone and how far left the
actual American population is and I
think we're gonna start to see that
increase especially on deals when it
comes to daca and you had various
senators grandstanding on it saying this
is my number one priority
how can your number one priority be
illegal citizens and not the citizens
you serve so to me that is completely
reprehensible and that's that's pointing
to a larger issue than the Democratic
Party as a whole absolutely right it's
an amazing thing to go to your
constituents and say the main thing that
I'm concerned about is everybody but you
everybody but you it's rangs high on my
list of priorities than you do
amber nobody wants to deport people that
is an unpleasant business it's kind of
icky it doesn't look good in the
headlines but this is our country we're
talking about this is our right to self
governance and this is 3.6 million
people is the responsible thing here to
enforce our laws and just deport them
like President Trump said at various
points on the campaign trail right a
responsible thing to do isn't always
popular I mean my number one choice
wouldn't be to just deport millions of
people not only is it not entirely
feasible but it's obviously not the nice
thing to do but when we're talking about
border security and illegal immigration
we have to consider the consequences of
our actions and the consequences of not
enforcing our immigration laws and a
huge side effect of daca was that in
2012 we had a humanitarian crisis on the
border where a bunch of young
unaccompanied minors were crossing being
left at the border crossing the border
on their own in incredibly dangerous
situations
times being sold into human trafficking
drug trafficking rings or joining gangs
so we have to consider what exactly the
side effects are when we grant amnesty
to people who decided to cross the
border in dangerous conditions and
illegally and so that's one of the
things that I think President Trump
should consider when he's making a deal
with the Democrats that's right it's
funny because there are so many
hysterical news cycles they seem to come
every 24 hours that we forget this major
event had happened just a few years ago
absolutely right now we have much more
news to talk about we have a lot but I
know what you're thinking right now
you're not thinking about docker you're
not think about the dreamers you're
thinking about my shave like my great
shave that I get did you know how I get
that great shave I get it from Dollar
Shave Club these guys are so good you've
heard me talk about them frequently it
is the best razor I've ever owned and I
usually buy nice razors I don't always
cheap out on the little guys I used to
just do those little throw aways then I
started I started to spend more money
and all the refills and all that you
have to go to the pharmacy I'm not gonna
do any of that anymore I'm only gonna do
Dollar Shave Club it is lovely so they
get very frequently I don't even use
shave cream but dr. Carver's shave
butter is just excellent feels really
nice gives you a close shave it's not
quite a cream it's not quite a gel no no
self-respecting man is going to use it
gel it's the shave butter really good
I'm not gonna give up my membership
Dollar Shave Club makes products for
your hair face skin shower everything
you need they use only the finest
premium ingredients and they deliver it
directly to you this is the key I would
go for months if not years at a time I'm
not kidding using the same razors
because I didn't want to go out and buy
anymore at you know the drugstore or
something this they send it right to you
for a very very low cost you don't have
to think about it it just comes right to
your door that means no more annoying
trips to the store cruising up and down
the aisles occasionally you go down that
aisle the men aren't supposed to go down
and you feel very awkward and you look
around like people are looking at you
you don't don't do any of that use
Dollar Shave Club for all of this razors
body cleanser hair gel and look a lot
we're talking about immigration a lot of
people in the US are from European
descended families in Europe they use
things like the bidet
they're very they're much more cleanly
in many ways than we are here if you
don't want to install it the day in your
house but you still want that ever fresh
clean feeling you can use a product to
make sure that you cleanse your own
derriere that comes from Dollar Shave
Club it's so it's so embarrassing to
talk about these things but they're
great products they have you covered
head to toe so now is a great time to
give Dollar Shave Club a try you can get
your first month of their best razor
their top-of-the-line razor along with
travel sized versions of the shave
butter body cleanser and that derriere
transformation equipment that low cost
bidet for just five dollars that is
basically free you should have to go and
get it right now it's really good it's
the best best razor I've ever used all
the other products are great too after
that replacement cartridge is ship for
just a few bucks a month it is the DSC
starter kit get yours for just $5
exclusively at dollarshaveclub.com
slash cough fa ce o VF e Fe that is a
very important word in these political
times co v fe fe dollarshaveclub.com
slash cough fa marshall what is it
slash pathetic go do it okay and I go oh
my you monster Marshall
how could you queue this up we're just
about to get to the sacramental view of
abortion that Democrats are taking and
all of our thoughts on the State of the
Union and the 500 million Democrat
responses that they're going to have
tonight that's the exact number but I'm
sorry if you're on Facebook and YouTube
you cannot watch it you've got to go
over to daily wired.com if you're
already there thank you very much you
keep the lights on you keep qoph fa in
my cup you keep dr. Korver shave butter
on my face if you haven't done that
already you go over there right now it's
$10 a month $100 for an annual
membership you get me you get the and
reclaim and show you got the Ben Shapiro
show you get the conversation you get to
ask questions during the conversation
many can watch few can ask questions
many are called few are chosen
I think I'm up next for the conversation
so go do it tonight we're gonna be doing
the State of the Union we're going to be
a hosting it'll be me Ben drew the The
Daily wire God King Jeremy boring we're
gonna have some special guests so we
haven't announced yet we're gonna be
smoking stogies and drinking too much
and
having a great time looking at president
Coffey and making fun of all the
Democrats so be sure to tune in for that
that's 5:00 to 9:00 p.m. on the west
coast and that is 8:00 to midnight I
guess on the east coast and it'll be a
lot of fun and probably going to imbibe
too much and it'll get a little rowdy so
go over there right now but none of that
matters what really matters is this the
leftist here's tumblr you're gonna need
it tonight they're gonna be six Democrat
responses to the State of the Union that
we're about to talk about you're gonna
it's gonna be coming out of the walls
it's gonna be coming out of the woodwork
make sure you protect yourself and your
family with the leftist tears tumblr the
only government approved fda-approved
vessel to store these those radioactive
leftist tears hotter cold always salty
and delicious go to daily wire calm
we'll be right back
all right panel
in other news Democrats are thrilled
that they have successfully blocked a
law preventing late-term abortion on
babies who can feel pain good job
Democrats you should feel really proud
of yourself huh
upon blocking this bill and sending
untold scores of late term pain capable
babies to certain death Chuck Schumer
high-fived fellow Democrat Heidi
Heitkamp Philip according to a Marist
Poll from late 2017 the majority of
American women support outlawing
abortion in 99% of cases now this
doesn't have to do with how they
identify pro-life or pro-choice kind of
malleable euphemisms when you get down
to the brass tacks and the bones of
abortion the the majority of women
oppose virtually all abortions why are
Democrat lawmakers so insistent on
keeping late term abortions legal well
because Democrats simply don't care
about popular opinion when it comes to
abortion their abortion orthodoxy is
unbending and they are going to make
certain that the United States stays in
the company of other nations which allow
third trimester abortions nations like
North Korea and China and this is this
is really unfortunate because they often
do this to their own political detriment
I mean DNC chairman Tom Perez found this
out earlier in the summer he was he was
going across the country trying to do
this soul-searching tour to get back in
touch with you know real America and
he's still living by the way I think
that soul-searching tour didn't turn up
too much yeah but he stops in Nebraska
right and he runs across this guy named
Keith Mello who is a pro-life Democrat
who's running for mayor of Omaha because
in order to be the mayor of Omaha you
have to be pro-life he endorses him and
then 24 hours later he's brought to his
knees by Democratic donors who say that
this is completely reprehensible you
have to be pro-choice to be Democrat and
even when it's to their own detriment
they they insist on following up with
this but I think that I think that the
pro-life democrat is actually going to
make a comeback and I think we saw this
the other day with the pain capable
action you had Democrats like Joe
Manchin of Indiana actually vote for the
legislation because they know well
they're from states that are
deep red and the Trump want and if
they're going to make a pitch to
religious or evangelical voters come
November you know they need to be able
to say that they're somewhat pro-life so
I think the the pro-life democrat might
be coming back it there's a very good
shot Joe Manchin I'm you said the
Indiana I think you went west for Jim
Joe Donnelly Joe Donnelly sitting at Joe
Donnelly mansion I see how you get them
confused because Joe Manchin is another
one who's this he's the last blue dog
left in the country and you you wonder
these guys gonna go completely extinct
or or that in order to win elections or
Democrats gonna have to come back and
contravene they're they're in fanatical
orthodoxy a little bit Ariel will
Democrat lawmakers have to answer for
this come election time or will this not
matter with their constituencies
Heitkamp is from North Dakota which
tilts in favor of abortion you know will
there be any consequences for them or as
Phillip predicts will there be a return
of the pro-life democrat or are they
going the way of the dodo well I think
for individuals like for instance Doug
Jones so he was just as bad as we
thought he was going to be and he he
voted in favor of not passing this ban
and so when he won the special election
Alabama you know there were lots of
people on the right and the left he said
you know what don't be hysterical Bob
Doug Jones he's not as bad as we think
he is when it comes to abortion he is
just as bad as we thought he is going to
be not to mention you have individuals
like Lisa Murkowski Susan Collins both
Republicans from Alaska and Maine
respectively who both voted against the
ban as well um and they've been a
perpetual headache for the GOP in
general so that really didn't shock me
everything from Obamacare and whatnot
they've been tremendous a tremendous
headache um when it comes to voting but
in general do I think we're gonna see
repercussions of this perhaps for
individuals like Doug Jones who were
sort of a smaller revival potentially of
the southern Democrat he will have to
answer for it because I don't think that
was in line with at all what his
constituents would have wanted in
Alabama in particular it happens to be
you know a very pro-life heavy state and
I would I applaud voters who respond to
that to those type of votes and say you
know what we don't
those heck elected officials making that
type of decisions so you know I I don't
know I'm cautious to say that there's
gonna be a revival of the southern
Democrat but I just don't see it as
being a much as much of a priority for
the left as this for the right and doug
jones is a good example because he only
won that election because of the gross
incompetence of republicans in that
state national republicans and guys like
luther strange who didn't find these
sordid stories about roy more and try to
push them and roy more who couldn't
fight those stories and obviously steve
Bannon you know it was pilloried for
losing alabama for republicans but as a
result now of that doug jones is gonna
have to answer because alabama hasn't
hasn't completely flipped overnight the
State of the Union is tonight everybody
what began as a sober affair during
which the president would present
remarks to Congress has now turned into
a televised circus Warren Harding was
the first president to broadcast the
address on the radio Truman was the
first to be televised Reagan began the
practice of inviting special guests
military law enforcement that sort of
thing it worked so phenomenally well
everybody has copied him since as is
true of most of the Reagan
administration Barack Obama famously
used to address I use the address rather
to criticize the Supreme Court well the
Supreme Court could not do anything in a
response they had to sit there like
puppets other than the great hero Sam
Alito who just shook his head and said
no Antonin Scalia famously boycotted the
State of the Union because it is a
frivolous parade amber is it time to end
this circus or is it good for the
American people to see these remarks
regardless of how silly they appear I
think circus is exactly the right word
and you know I've already heard so many
liberal media pundits complaining that
the State of the Union is going to be
boring because President Trump is going
to read a scripted speech and I think
it's really funny to finally have them
admit that the way that Trump speaks
from the heart and the way that he
usually addresses his constituents is
actually really not only entertaining
but just really gripping so that's been
interesting to see on dan Twitter
and on TV and the like now the
Democratic response I think is going to
be the really interesting part of the
State of the Union tonight because they
have none other than a Kennedy
delivering the response to trump State
of the Union proving that they learned
absolutely nothing from the 2016
election because they've chosen yet
another establishment you know and said
well what's what's really amazing about
this too what's amazing is that one of
these responses to the State of the
Union have never gone well the ever
either party they call it the curse of
the State of the Union response and so
who do they pick to break a curse they
pick a Kennedy because nobody knows had
a break curse is quite like Kennedy's
isn't there at Phillip politics is a
major form of American entertainment we
elected the pioneer of reality TV to
become the president himself does this
obsession with politics as entertainment
sure that we've decayed as a culture as
CS Lewis might describe or is it good
that Americans are so we're so plugged
into our political process I'm sure the
ratings are gonna be through the roof
well you know politics is definitely
downstream from culture and that's how
President Trump floated into the Oval
Office he's fun to watch I mean if you
go to a trump rally it's a rock concert
because everyone is excited about what
he's going to say and everyone was kind
of waiting for him to say something
crazy that's the way it is tonight you
know I think there is a little bit of
frustration that he's going to be on
script but last year during the joint
address he got rave reviews he was
incredibly presidential especially when
he was talking to the widow of that Navy
SEAL and I think that we'll probably see
something similar he's going to be
plugging his past achievements and
pitching reform on on immigration and I
think he's got an opportunity to show
that he's kind of the adult in the room
when it comes to you know making these
deals because Democrats have just shut
down the government you know quickly to
bounce off with the last guest set yeah
Democrats definitely have multiple
personality disorders and choosing Joe
Kennedy the third he is just amazing I
mean what screams more American than an
Ivy League blue-blooded
trust fund babies rich
Pennybags life that's gonna be the next
state of the Union response how could it
not Ariel we have we've got to go we
over run out of time but do you have any
final thoughts on this ridiculous circus
tonight well J cost from the Weekly
Standard had a good quote he said the
State of the Union is much too kingly
for Republic and I kind of air on that
side when it comes to the State of the
Union address I think at one point you
know it serves a purpose for updating
Congress and now it has become sort of a
self aggrandizing event on behalf of the
president that's sort of it that's like
Burger King Lee it isn't there's nothing
actually regal about it it's so I see
the point we are worshipping at the
altar of the presidency in many ways
when we watch it but my problem isn't
that the affair is to monarchist or
something my affair and my problem with
it is it so crass and vulgar it's like
he sends shivers up my spine on that
front but I think that at this point you
know it is entertainment i side with
Phil at this point like you know bring
it on we're lots of wine I also got you
in for a penny in for a pound so goes
the Republic c'est la vie
okay panel thank you all for being here
we have Philip Wegman we have Ariel
Davidson and we have an amp or Athey
that's it that's our entire show be sure
to tune in we're gonna be broadcasting
within just a matter of hours I probably
start drinking about now we're gonna
have it'll be me it'll be Ben it'll be
drew
it'll be Daily wire God King Jeremy
boring the special can I tell them I
can't tell I can't tell you the special
guest star but it's gonna be a lot of
fun so make sure you tune in that's
gonna be starting just a few hours 8
p.m. Eastern Time
do not miss it it'll be on our Facebook
on our YouTube on thei Lee Weyer make
sure to check it out there until
tomorrow folks or I suppose until
tonight I'm Michael Knowles this is the
Michael Nolt show I will see you soon
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Marshall Benson executive producer
Jeremy Borah senior producer Jonathan
hey supervising producer
Mathis Glover our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Alex zingaro
audio is mixed by Mike Cora Mina herons
makeup is by Joshua Avera the Michael
Noel's show is a daily wire for word
publishing production copyright for word
publishing 2018